people are backing up their their mouths  people got big ambitious you talk a lot  of things you've got those quotes on  Instagram but you don't put in the work  and I totally agree with you and guess  what that's I don't feel bad like it's  hard to feel bad and the thing is look  I'm not I used to like disadvantages and  things of that nature but I say I don't  feel bad I'm sitting here spending  ungodly amounts of time my time that's  valuable to me from forget about money  family like little little little rest  here somewhere you know and I'm putting  out content and I'm answering questions  and I'm giving it to you but if you  don't take it it's free I'm not selling  thousand dollar ebooks there's no  [ __ ] 500 dollar course like some of  these other [ __ ] on Instagram is free  right I'm giving you free  [Music]